alors on s'est rencontré sur un site de
rencontre moi j'étais encore marié mais
c'était en fin de mariage
donc j'ai rencontré Lionel voilà donc on
sait plus il est venu me voir moi
j'étais à l'époque dans une clinique
mais bon si à l'époque pour perdre du
poids bon d'accord ça il est venu me
voir un soir et deux jours après il est
revenu me voir et puis après on sait
plus quitter moi j'ai quitté mon mari
j'ai divorcé
donc il y a 26 ans d'écart entre vous
vous êtes toujours heureux ensemble oui
bien sûr toujours amoureux depuis 11 ans
la différence d'âge franchement alors je
vous dis
je trouve que elle est pas elle est pas
criante voilà quand on voit je vous le
dis franchement
ça choque quand même toujours pas dans
les mœurs franchement
voilà je trouve pas que ce soit voilà
franchement ça nous choque pas
voilà
vous avez raconte
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup de problèmes à
cause de ça alors justement on va en
parler dans un instant justement avant
tout votre famille au départ à la Régie
quand vous avez des enfants vous avez
des enfants mairies moi j'ai un fils qui
a un an de moins que Lionel qu'est-ce
qui vous a dit oh ben de toute façon on
se parle plus ah depuis depuis Lionel
non non ça passait pas donc bon vous
avez dit je vais mettre avec Lionel qui
a 26 moi mon fils m'a dit bon tu fais ce
que tu veux de ta vie tu fais ce que tu
veux maman bon moi c'est tout moi c'est
comme ça bon ben ça me plaît pas bon ben
j'ai laissé tomber comme je suis parti
de la maison
je me suis éloigné donc ça ça a coupé
encore plus facilement les liens et le
reste de votre famille ah ben le reste
c'est pareil personne ouais
bon j'ai deux sœurs et un frère mais bon
mais je vois plus versant tout le monde
vous a tourné le dos mais voilà oui
c'est fou Lionel vous comment ça
enregistre Mireille à l'âge de mes
parents oui donc la parité elle est là
c'est de son côté plus personne lui
parle moi non plus je suis une sœur qui
m'ont tourné le dos moi plus personne
tout ça parce que vous sortez avec une
personne plus que vous et oui mais tout
le monde
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit ils étaient
dans l'espoir que c'était une passade
pour Mireille qu'elle voulait sortir
avec un petit jeune et que
automatiquement ça allait passer à cette
dame qui est entrée dans ma vie et que
moi j'allais peut-être rentrer dans les
clous avec quelqu'un de mon âge
et finalement c'est pour ça qu'on nous
prêtait pas 24 heures ensemble tout le
monde espérait que chacun allait rentrer
vous avez des enfants
mais un an qui sont grands qui sont pour
trois sur quatre majeures maintenant
voilà il s'émancipe ils font leur vie et
vous ils ont ils ont toujours accepté
Mireille
ben moi elle a accepté Mireille
c'est normal
il faisait le malheureux mais en fait
depuis un an ou deux
j'avais presque des remords et des
regrets on sentait coupable moi je me
sentais coupable quand il est rentré
dans ma vie elle était mariée je me
sentais coupable de faire du mal à un
monsieur par par translation et
finalement c'est vrai qu'on a appris que
lui-même était doublement en couple donc
après le sentiment de culpabilité
donc voilà
aujourd'hui ça fait 11 ans que vous êtes
ensemble ça
à cette histoire c'est une belle
histoire d'amour mais aujourd'hui ça
s'est gâté puisque vous avez médiatisé
votre affaire votre histoire est
passionnante vous êtes venu la raconter
sur plusieurs plateaux dont le plateau
de de balance ton poste
pourquoi vous avez voulu en parler à la
télé déjà
vous aviez mon envie de montrer votre
amour et que voilà
moi je trouve ça super mignon
tout simplement initialement c'était ça
c'était partager notre amour parce que
pour nous ça semble pour moi en tout cas
ça me semble normal d'être avec
quelqu'un de plus âgé je me pose pas la
question en fait c'est dans la normalité
voilà vous avez fait plusieurs émissions
et après vos multiples passages à la
télé Mireille et Lionel ont reçu
énormément de réflexions déplacées du
genre
via les réseaux sociaux par exemple
c'est toujours récurrent on nous appelle
on nous appelle le couple Macron c'est
la référence ultime ça va ça va encore
la situation d'aujourd'hui démontre le
contraire que il y a quelque chose de
fiduciaire entre nous quelque chose
écoute-moi bon ben je vais me payer un
petit jeune
ça va au bout de 11 ans ça a été sur les
réseaux et évidemment et votre famille
aussi
dans la vie on vous le fait ressentir
par exemple si j'accompagne chez le
gilet Mireille on va demander à ce que
son fils en l'occurrence moi je reste
dans la salle d'attente vous voyez c'est
pas rentré dans les bourses alors qu'on
indique que je suis son compagnon ben
votre fils peut attendre madame mais
docteur bon alors des moments c'est
rigolo il y a certains
on est habitué maintenant c'est quoi la
pire chose que vous ayez vécu la pire
voilà le moment le plus difficile ce
qu'on va parler après de votre situation
qui est
c'est ce qu'on vit actuellement mais au
niveau de au niveau de les réflexions
et de profit ça ça je peux pas
l'entendre quand on m'envoie sur les
réseaux sociaux des liasses de billets
oui en gif si il y avait quelque chose
de fin voilà vous voyez ce que je veux
dire l'argent que c'est atroce il y a
pas c'est à part vous emmener dans une
voiture alors attendez attendez on va on
va en parler dans un instant merci
Raymond
alors vous avez résilié votre bail en
2019 vous viviez vous dites dans un
taudis c'est un appartement
c'était assez cher et puis à ce genre sa
voisiner les 800 €
un petit peu un petit peu plus grand
qu'un studio vous habitez où vous
habitez Aix-en-Provence d'accord 800
euros pour un petit sujet
récurrent la cage d'escalier était on ne
peut plus dangereuse Mireille n'est pas
tout jeune donc voilà il y avait des
moments d'éclairage demande pas
l'éclairage j'ai pu en payer quand même
je trouve un montant bien sûr
relativement onéreux pour pour
studio
en fait c'était
difficile
alors vous résignez votre bail en 2019
et vous tentez de déménager sans succès
[Musique]
vous louez l'appartement c'est ça
parfaitement qu'est-ce qu'on mange
qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit combien
d'agences alors déjà la différence d'âge
choque les propriétaires d'accord
pourquoi on n'en sait rien d'accord
pour vous c'est pour parce que je suis
trop vieille et que si il m'arrive
quelque chose on demande de produire un
certificat d'autonomique quand même un
certificat d'orange si je suis autonome
puisse établir et établissent un
certificat d'autonomie
en fait si dans l'éventualité d'un
impayé au niveau des loyers ça permet de
nous dégager malgré le grand âge de
Mireille
donc
vous n'avez pas de logement depuis
combien de temps et trois ans trois ans
vous dormez où alors on fait de la ou
dans la voiture
on a tout essayé en fait tous les types
de quand on peut on va dans des petits
hôtels d'accord un petit peu on a fait
des Airbnb alors là par contre les
Airbnb pendant le confinement c'était
atroce et là il fallait rester confiné
bon on avait quelques économies mais
dans les Airbnb
et de la main à la main
Airbnb
à louer pendant l'année mais nous de
mars Au mois de juin
le quota de ces nuité au propriétaire du
Airbnb le dépasser donc 2700 euros comme
ça en payant de la main quand vous
prenez un logement éphémère type Airbnb
ça se passe toujours la même manière on
en sait quelque chose puisque sur trois
ans on peut produire à peu près 7
factures que ce soit hôtel que ce soit
Airbnb que ce soit location de véhicule
parce qu'on n'avait pas de voiture
600 euros par mois
pour dormir dedans
mais elle nous a donné c'est ce que vous
avez en ce moment oui d'accord vous
dormez dedans
on est dans un camping d'accord il
paraît que vous allez devoir partir ben
on va être obligé de partir parce que on
peut y rester que on peut pas vivre
quelques mois
vous allez retourner dans la voiture
après
alors en plus maintenant on a que nos
salaires on a plus d'économie quand on a
fini le mois on est à 0 mais vous
touchez
où vous êtes touchez pas d'aide
on a droit aucune aide non non
j'ai j'ai une retraite je vais vous dire
combien j'ai de retraite vous avez 400
maintenant 1450 euros de retraite bon
j'ai droit j'ai pas le droit d'APL j'ai
pas droit 1450 euros de retraite comme
vous la touchez comment vous la touchez
en fait
d'accord
ça fait 2250 € donc vous pourriez
trouver un logement oui mais non parce
que c'est les agences ne peuvent pas
considération mon invalidité d'accord
donc c'est pas 2250 euros l'agence ne
tiennent pas compte des revenus de
l'impérativité donc c'est 1400 euros
donc moi avec mes revenus je ne peux
prétendre qu'un loyer qu'un appartement
qui fait 30% de mes revenus 30% de 1400
euros
même un petit appartement est-ce que
vous avez essayé
mais n'importe mais personne pourquoi
personne
commission d'attribution de logement le
28 juin
bon ben on nous fait comprendre qu'il y
a des gens dans une situation ou encore
plus précaire que la nôtre
les gens savent que vous êtes dans la
dans la rue
dans la rue c'est simple il faut faire
très attention quand vous êtes dans la
rue c'est on en sait quelque chose
maintenant style elle est se laver au
centre d'accueil et d'orientation
quand on est quand on est à la rue même
dans un véhicule au départ les gens sont
choqués ils vous voient tous les jours
il se demande ce que vous faites puis
ils comprennent petit à petit que vous
vivez en fait dans la rue et puis après
vous faites corps avec la rue c'est à
dire que ils prennent l'habitude de
manière habituer de vous voir alors nous
on essaie d'être invisible au mieux
parce qu'on sait pas question de fierté
mais il y a quand même une honte à
comment surable à être dans ces
conditions de vie comme ça donc on
essaie d'être plus propre possible et
d'ailleurs on voit bien quand on va au
service d'accueil et d'orientation
d'Aix-en-Provence et d'ailleurs je les
en remercie vraiment pour pour leur
gentillesse leur présence quand on
récupère le courrier ce qu'on est
domicile
automatiquement mais il voyait bien
qu'on est des gens normaux pourtant en
fait c'est pas un jugement de valeur
vis-à-vis de quiconque nous nous on ne
juge personne mais il voyait bien que on
vous avait donné par mois vous vivez
dans la rue et aujourd'hui donc il y a
il y a pas de solution pour vous alors
de toute façon si on peut trouver un
appartement mais on nous demande un
garant qu'on a pas une caution alors que
mes parents pourraient donc on n'a pas
les finances c'est à cause de c'est le
du fait que votre différence d'âge tout
le monde vous a tourné le dos donc vous
vous retrouvez seul
donc en fait n'est aucune solution
on a notre chienne avec nous c'est tout
voilà non mais pleure pas parce que moi
je vais vous expliquer une petite
situation c'est à dire que au départ qui
m'en dit en silence meurt de faim en
silence voilà vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire qu'au départ on crier
dans un bocal et moi j'ai décidé de plus
créer dans un bocal
depuis le 13 juin parce que le 13 juin
en fait on était sur une place de
village où la journée on et on pouvait
et la nuit on se cachait pour dormir
dans la voiture et en fait ce qui s'est
passé sur cette place du village voilà
c'était 5h50 du matin
j'étais sur le côté passager je me
mettais la ceinture pour qu'elle puisse
me caler la tête et ma compagne va aux
toilettes publiques tout simplement
voilà on a plus rien à cacher tout façon
on a plus rien à perdre et ce qui s'est
passé c'est que j'étais sur le côté
droit m'accompagne revient des toilettes
publiques
elle s'assied et moi je suis réveillé
par un grand coup de klaxon en fait
c'était la tête de ma compagne qui
tapait contre le volant voilà elle était
en train de faire une embolie pulmonaire
tout simplement voilà donc moi j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu pour pour sauver Mireille
pour lui permettre de respirer il y a
été prise en charge par les pompiers qui
l'emmenait sur Manosque à l'hôpital de
Manosque et dans l'heure elle était
transférée en urgence vitale par
hélicoptère à l'hôpital Nord
on a décidé de plus rester en silence
bien sûr
c'est plus possible on espère que votre
venue ici que votre cri du coeur va
peut-être mobiliser des des personnes
qui disent on va peut-être leur louer
quelque chose que vous êtes sérieux
voilà vous êtes pour démarrer parce que
comme on n'a pas de de garant et on a
zéro il faut vous faire confiance
et après bon il faut donner après un peu
plus on pourra mais au départ voilà
ce qu'il nous faut même un appartement à
500 ou 600 euros on peut le payer mais
on peut pas donner 1000 ou 1500 euros
d'avance etc
c'est incroyable parce que c'est
vraiment une situation donc
bien sûr c'est ça parce que parce que là
on est dans un camping on paye presque
900 euros par mois pour un bungalow
voilà donc c'est le chat qui se mord la
queue c'est à dire que on a des chances
jusqu'au mois de mars c'est possible
après pas censé période estivale et là
ça passe à la semaine à 600 euros la
semaine
700 juillet
et on a les mêmes chances que monsieur
madame tout le monde
veut pas rester spécialement à côté d'un
on peut partir n'importe où on est on
s'en fiche on a plus d'attache n'importe
j'espère que votre cul du coeur va vous
dire soit on va essayer de faire des
démarches aussi nous aussi de notre côté
pour vous aider Mireille et Lionel merci
c'était très important de vous avoir ce
soir